economía aquí en directo américa en
france 24 está conmigo en el estudio
jorge hurtado jorge muy buenas noches
comenzamos en europa porque allí hay
nerviosismo luego de que rusia decidiera
cortar una de las vías clave para poder
suministrar gas a la unión europea que
van a hacer
santiago tras la noticia el precio del
gas se disparó hasta en un 20 por ciento
moscú sancionó las filiales europeas de
la empresa estatal gazprom un día
después de que ucrania interrumpieron
importantes rutas de tránsito de gas
rusia cortó el suministro a bulgaria y
polonia como recordemos entre las
empresas sancionadas por rusia ésta
gazprom germanía una empresa de comercio
almacenamiento y transmisión de energía
que alemania puso bajo administración fi
de usuaria el mes pasado para garantizar
o intentar garantizar el suministro
energético
la sanción más importante fue hacia el
propietario de la parte polaca al
gasoducto yamal-europa que lleva el gas
ruso a europa este gasoducto tiene una
longitud de más de 4.000 kilómetros y
parte desde torio al occidente de rusia
y va hasta la ciudad alemana de
frankfurt antes pasa por vela roja y
también polonia su capacidad máxima es
de 33 mil millones de metros cúbicos de
gas anuales darnos una idea eso es todo
lo que consume españa en un año de gas
las sanciones rusas son una respuesta a
las sanciones europeas y hablemos ahora
de rusia porque continúan aumentando los
ingresos debido a la venta precisamente
de los hidrocarburos del gas y del
petróleo qué es lo que pasa allí bueno
es que según la agencia internacional de
energía rusia aumentó en 50 por ciento
sus ingresos este año esto pese a que
muchas refinerías rehúyen a sus
suministros por las sanciones moscú ganó
alrededor de 20 mil millones de dólares
al mes en lo que va de este año por las
ventas combinadas de crudo y productos
que ascienden a unos 8 millones de
barriles al día el petróleo ruso
continúa fluyendo en el comercio en que
grandes petroleras internacionales como
shell y total energy sse se
comprometieron a dejar de comprar china
india siguen comprando los cargamentos
que ya no se quieren en europa dejemos a
europa cruzamos el atlántico jorge
hablamos de eeuu porque el senado
confirmó al presidente de la reserva
federal para un segundo mandato y con la
inflación que está presentando ese país
bueno hoy era un pavo recibió el
respaldo de la mayoría de los senadores
con 80 votos a favor y 10 en contra
power asumió en 2018 cuando fue nominado
por donald trump y en 2021 volvió a ser
nominado para el cargo por joe baden
powell intenta combatir la inflación más
alta que eeuu ha experimentado en cuatro
décadas la reserva federal que dirige
prevé más subidas de los tipos de
interés con el objetivo de ralentizar la
actividad económica lo suficiente para
frenar la inflación pero con el riesgo
de generar una recesión económica en ese
país hablemos de américa latina' alza de
los precios parecen no tener contención
hoy se conocía el índice de precios al
consumidor en argentina con la mayor
subida interanual en tres décadas según
el instituto nacional de estadísticas y
censo la tasa de inflación experimentó
el mes pasado un incremento interanual
del 58 por ciento el mayor avance desde
enero de 1992 los alimentos y las
bebidas no alcohólicas' fueron las
categorías que más subieron a nivel
mensual en abril específicamente allí
productos como el aceite el pan cereales
carnes y lácteos mostraron subidas
arriba del 5% para los acuerdos con el
fondo monetario internacional el
gobierno de alberto fernández estableció
como una máxima prioridad tratar de
frenar el aumento incesante de los
precios pero hasta ahora pues no lo ha
logrado y hablemos ahora de los
indicadores cómo les va las bolsas
empezamos con wall street que cerró
mixto pero su principal indicador el
down jones de industriales bajó un 0,33
por ciento sumando una nueva jornada
tras otra turbulenta por el temor de la
inflación que se vive en ese país en
europa las acciones cayeron un día
después de que los datos de inflación de
eeuu aumentarán las preocupaciones sobre
el impacto de la subida de los tipos de
interés en el crecimiento económico y en
américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
avanzó un 1 24 por ciento apoyada por
las acciones del sector bancario con
subida para por ejemplo el banco itaú
bradesco y el banco do brazil muchas
gracias jorge por esta actualización del
mundo económico a continuación en
directo américa el debate